hello uh thank you for having me my name
is rinky agarwal
i will be talking to you about
hereditary cancer risk
assessment um
our objectives today is to provide an
overview of hereditary cancer syndromes
to uh review the obtaining of a family
history and to
illustrate the importance of obtaining
this history
to review different risk assessment
strategies probably
to identify patients at risk of
irritable cancer syndromes
based on current guidelines to review
the genetic testing
consultation with a genetic counseling
professional
and the meaning and implications of
genetic test results
and then from there a a
review of management strategies
including referral to
the genetics professionals as well as
specialists
as indicated based on the assessment
of risk for the patient um
for uh reviewing generates we would need
to review some basics
this is going back to medical school
information
that we are all familiar with but a
review is uh well placed
in uh most discussions um
genes are are present on either
autosomes or
sex chromosomes and if passed down on an
autosomal
chromosome and uh one
copy being affected is enough as seen on
that left hand uh diagram
uh that would be nonsensical dominant
versus it requires
uh two carrier parents and then for them
both
to pass down uh the carrier gene
to the uh to the progeny to the child
uh and then both copies in that
individual are being
are affected would lead to a dinosaur
recessive condition
most cancer syndromes are inherited in a
dominant manner but there are some
recessive conditions as well
penetrance is the other factor to
recognize
which is that there is a age-based
penetrance of
most cancer conditions in patients who
are carriers and at
risk of having cancer syndromes
and that can be complete penetrance for
example fap
where there is 100 likelihood of
developing colon cancer
versus incomplete penetration and that
would be that you can be a carrier for a
mutation and then there is
um a reduced or incomplete penetrance
there'll be people who are not affected
by
the condition even though they carry the
gene such as for example ovary cancer
the situation of the rca one nature
expressivity is that the same cancer
gene
or a risk gene can basically cause
different kinds of cancers
a classic example of that is lymph
syndrome which
has multiple different cancers that the
individual would be at risk for
but some people will develop colon
cancer and other people in the family
will develop endometrial cancer and so
forth
uh there's also a difference in the age
of onset
or conditions uh for the cancer
condition
in families with presumably the same
gene being the cause for developing the
cancer or the risk for developing
cancer there is the possibility of
having what we think of as germline
mutations to be
new that would be where the mutation
occurs
either in the egg or the sperm of the
parent the parent is unaffected
and then that egg or sperm when
fertilized
is now present in the child who is
uh who's a denoble mutation and now
that person is uh capable of uh
passing it down to the progeny so that
an example of that would be for many
syndrome
and the other uh a little caveat to sort
of recognize
is that patients can have a autosomal
dominant condition again
lymph syndrome would be an example of
that but if they had
both alleles by allelic mutations
of that gene then they can have
a marked increase in the risk of cancer
such as in the constitutional mismatch
repair deficiency in this example on the
right hand side
showing um two msh six mutations
leading to lint syndrome in the parents
and then the child
has a quarter chance of having uh biolic
carrier status with increased risk of
childhood
and adult cancers
so the way these will develop
cancer is that you have all cancer
starting as a genetic change
and uh these are generally somatic
with both coffees being affected
but what if you went through
uh with a family where one of the copies
is already affected and then it only
takes the second hit or the second copy
to become
affected as well to have the person is
homozygous
for a deficient uh
gene with its function in a tumor
suppressor setting
and that leads to overtime development
of
cancer so you're basically a step closer
to
[Music]
the development of cancer in patients
who have an autosomal dominant mutation
in atrium or suppressor
so in summary most cancer syndromes are
dominant
they have variable expressivity and
penetrance based on the type of mutation
we're talking about
and they have this two hit hypothesis
where they're step closer to
developing a cancer reviewing a view of
the common
syndromes
the most germline mutations
have an increase in the risk of various
types of cancers
and there are different organs at risk
and recognizing that pattern
allows you to identify patients at risk
and once you identify the risk you can
say that
you identified it because of one cancer
in the person or in the family
and it allows you to define the
additional risks that the person may
have or their family might share
so um you have a person here
who is coming into your office for
testing
over genetic counseling and testing and
then as you draw a pedigree realize
that on the paternal side you have
a ant with ovary cancer and a cousin
with breast cancer who is a brc1
mutation carrier
and your patient has a chance of sharing
a mutation about 25 percent of the time
uh or 12 and a half percent of the time
no 25 percent of time
in this uh situation and so yeah
obtaining a paternal family history in
a syndrome that is primarily for
women's cancers uh so that you're not
misled by
the type of cancer or organ involved
becomes important uh in the brca one and
two
uh in the northern uh european ancestry
uh brca1 mutation uh are common one in
300 a modest uh department and brca2 is
still
a relatively rare mutation with 1 800
people being carriers
there are certain differences in the
types of cancers seen with the brca one
mutation carries in triple negative
breast cancers
and the brca2 mutations having triple
hormone receptor positive breast cancers
there are ethnic variations without a
mutation seen in the
astronomically jewish or french canadian
icelandic populations where there is
recurrent or repetitive mutations we're
starting from a founder effect at some
point
in previous generations uh brca2 is
notable for also presence of
male breast cancer and they have an
increased risk of prostate pancreatic
cancer any somewhat increased risk of
melanomas as well
yeah the next thing to discuss would be
lynch syndrome where you have a person
uh
uh coming in and the family history
would have a
preponderance of colon polyps
colon cancer especially early onset
colon cancer
the possibility of having endometrial
cancer
but when you are doing that assessment
it's also important to
look at uh your patient
and they came to you with an established
lin syndrome diagnosis
and if you obtain the family history on
the other side you would see the same
family history potentially on that side
and doing a assessment of that so that
you can
offer counseling offer testing identify
risk becomes important as well as seen
on the maternal side of this individual
uh lynch syndrome has
a has
multiple genes that would confer risk
and they
have differences in the likelihood of
occurrence of cancer
based on the gene that's involved
we've talked about the recessive
condition where you can get
a marked increase in childhood cancers
and cancers in general the
testing recommendations are currently
based on the test and amsterdam
guidelines
but you get colon cancer is the
predominant risk and the highest
lifetime risk
endometrial cancer especially in females
in the family would be
the other significant risk as well as
some
increase in the risk of ovarian cancer
and then there is
upper intestinal tract cancers gastric
and small bowel
and then urothelial cancers so renal
pelvis
bladder skin tumors sebaceous neoplasms
and then pancreatic cancer
can be noted as well uh
hdgc or hereditary diffuse gastric
cancer
uh is uh noted to have a cdh1 mutation
in about 25 to 50 percent of patients
who
suffer from hereditary diffuse gastric
cancer
um if a cdh1
gene mutation is identified you can have
other um
other mutate other cancers seen in those
patients as well such as lobular breast
cancer
or potentially significant uh colorectal
cancers
and so looking at the actual pathology
report
looking at what exact cancer was seen
and identified in the patient of the
patient's family
can give you clues to the things that
you might find when you do
extend testing to that individual
lyfromany syndrome a
constellation of tumors where you really
see
a mock increase in the family of
cancers they can be several different
types of cancers including epithelial
and connective tissue cancers there are
certain uh
tumors that are uh hormonal tumors like
soft tissue sarcomas or adrenal
tumors and then also breast cancer seen
at
less than 30 years of age uh should make
uh one think about lip from any syndrome
uh this has uh defined uh lyfromany
syndrome criteria classic criteria
that is utilized
to assess a person for screening
and uh there are
certainly areas of centers of excellence
that will follow lead from any syndrome
patients and have enhanced screening
modalities utilized for those patients
to give them protection
there is a growing a large and a growing
list of mutations
that can be identified and are now
included in the multi-gene panels
that multiple companies now have
available to them
and they have different degrees
of penetrance and expressivity
uh and some of them are autosomal
recessive
in nature
knowing about the presence or occurrence
of these patterns so that you're
thinking about
it is the thing that
i would leave people with
as the big message to take home
simple things like not exactly cancers
but
multiple different fibroids early onset
fibroids because fibroids are generally
seen in patients who are
older closer to 30s and 40s but you have
very young patients with having multiple
fibroids
having
increased risk of
renal cell cancers and a fumarate
hydrodase
gene mutation giving you hlrcc
if you have rare type of cancers
giving you
an example as a small sarcasm of the
ovary hypocalcemic type
and an evaluation might show you a smart
foraging mutation
uh check two is now included in most
multi-gene panels
and uh it gives rise to modest western
colon
uh cancer risk uh there's specific types
uh or locations of mutations where
you can define a difference even within
the check 2
mutations a difference in the
expressivity of
it with the cancers and the likelihood
of cancer development
um check two is one of the
mutations or genes where consideration
is being given to
a polygenic risk scores which is
a topic that really can't be covered in
a short talk uh such as the one we're
doing today
uh and then uh mutih
or we as we refer to as mute yh is an
autosomal recessor condition with colon
polyphosis
and colon cancer
as you find information or recognize
pattern
the strategies to use is to ask for your
community look with a new community for
a genetics professional
to look at national guidelines change
reviews
or do a literature search for uh
assessment and understanding of that
disease we can
disease risk so you can comfortably talk
to people about it
um
if you have an increase in the risk of
cancer you basically are also able to
identify what organs are at risk and
what strategies
can be used and this is a continuously
evolving field
the recognition of the pattern within a
family is going to require
collection of a family history um
the importance of this cannot be over
emphasized
obtaining a three-generation uh family
history
uh especially for cancer but also for
unaffected
and medical conditions and that these
should be analyzed and then be updated
regularly as patients return to you for
subsequent follow-up is something that
has been now
supported by multiple guidelines by
different national groups there is
a uh the
growth of screening tools so you have
within the electronic medical record or
in paper forms checklists that can be
developed or have been developed by
different groups
that will allow you to say um
okay this person is falling within a
pattern
where genetic testing or counseling can
be considered
uh and as this the family histories of
patients evolve
over time uh important again emphasizing
the importance of updating that family
history regularly
the checklist and your sense of
increased risk would fall with
if you have multiple cancers early onset
of cancer
rare type of cancers that
fall within certain disease paradigms
[Music]
if they have associated birth defects
and certain types of cancers or they
have a
heritage where there where there is
known founder effect
uh in the family would uh all uh
prompt you to basically consider genetic
testing
or genetic counseling powered by genetic
testing uh
in those patients so
once you say that there may be increased
risk and
it's a it's appropriate to consider um
uh uh appropriate
it's appropriate to consider uh genetic
counseling there are uh now tools
uh that have been developed for uh
determining that uh this person
should get counseling or testing and
uh that would typically be to a
genetics professional uh
a referral to a center of expertise
uh with expertise in this is important
because the generic counselor can do the
appropriate assessment
uh do pre-test and post-test counseling
to
determine the appropriateness of generic
tests
and certainly you may have knowledge of
counselors present
in your community and it is very good if
you have those services in your
community
general counseling is somewhat difficult
to identify
and is not as widely available as we
would like
so there are national resources or
websites that will
provide you with information on the
on the availability of counselors uh and
there has been a growth in
the use of telegenetics so that you can
be somewhat remote from the counselor
and they may still be able to provide
services to
your patient
other there has been a growth of
direct to provider uh or director
of consumer genetic testing
and as far as providers is concerned
there is
need to recognize that it requires a
fair bit
of understanding and expertise in cancer
genetics
you have to be able to provide the
counseling the risk assessment the
education
and adequate and competent
interpretation of test results you have
to counsel them
and it's required that you counsel them
about uh
cost insurance coverage for it and then
regulatory issues
long-term care and health care insurance
issues and
and to be familiar with the rules and
regulations
and federal protection for patients
when they go through a genetic risk
assessment
when this is not done correctly
there is liability when you don't offer
counseling there's also liability if the
counseling is not offered well
such as failure to obtain a family
history or appropriate testing failure
to refer the patient to an appropriate
genetics
genetics professional misinterpretation
of test results leading to a incorrect
intervention being done
failure to encourage sharing of
results family members in offering or
facilitating
cascade testing and failure to comply
with use of
appropriate labs and consent forms in
new york state you have to have a
written consent form
in order to go through testing
when you make a referral you're using
criteria
to establish the
referral streams and then when the
patient is seen by a genetic counselor
these are trained professionals that are
uh familiar and have expertise in a in
explaining the uh medical genetics
and uh family implications for genetic
genetic contribution to disease uh
they are uh trained in handling
uh assessment for testing justifying
testing
making plans when the patient chooses
not to have testing
and if they were to go through and
identify risk
uh counseling the patient on that risk
so they have uh these are the basic
tenets the genetic counseling
tenets which is to do an assessment to
educate the patient
to have guidance and walk through
different scenarios
for when the test is positive or
negative
what is what expectation can the patient
have
from getting that information
understanding the motivation
for going through this process of
assessment and testing
and then to help with uh informed
decision making with regard to testing
and possibly for further management
beyond
as i said at least in new york state
where i practice it is required that
they should be
the informed consent where the patient
is
given an opportunity to review the
information and consent to it
not simply signing a piece of paper but
actually understanding the implications
of the
uh of the process and the test results
um once the
test once the counseling is done uh
the components are identified is who's
the best person to test what's the most
appropriate testing
which lab to use whether should they
should be
a priority to the genetic testing and
whether any samples need to be stored
what are the reasons for testing and how
uh what sort of recommendations can come
out of anticipated results
and who else in the family will be
impacted by the testing as well as
coverage eventually for
the testing from insurance and
out-of-pocket expenses
uh one important thing to recognize is
when the person
when the patient is referred to the
genetic counselor they may look at
and do an assessment based on the
patient's
personal and family history and
determine that they don't actually
qualify for genetic testing they would
actually be inappropriate
to put them through that process and so
that's
that's a possibility once
patients go through the counseling and
they accept testing
recognizing that this is dna based
testing so you are
using a diagnostic tool not a screening
test
there are myriad labs myriad but there
are many labs
who offer testing and um
they have different things in their
panels they have different uh
databases that they refer to where
where they're drawing information the
scientific information to
allow you to have interpretation of
the results and the test interpretation
is fairly complex
and then once the test result comes back
it needs to be applied to the
family history and the patient's
specific information
to come up with recommendations the
extent of testing can be pretty wide
you have a known mutation you can do a
single side testing as you can see in
the center of that
graphic you have founder effects
uh in the groups that we've referred to
before in this talk
and then you can do basically just found
a mutation testing
a single gene or like a full assessment
of a particular gene based on a pattern
of disease uh you have a pattern of
disease but you're trying to catch
everything that could be a possibility
using multi-gene panels
and then a little bit less used right
now but the
existence of holyxone or genome
based testing
insurance authorization or possibly even
pre-authorization
is necessary to run the test uh
there is the potential as you run
through just like you do with
other multiple tests there is potential
to have
bearings or variants of uncertain
significance which is basically that
there is a difference in
uh there is some change in the
[Music]
in the uh genome and
it is not classifiable at this point uh
when compared to clinvar or other
databases into either
a benign mutation or a pathogenic
mutation and those
then remain in that
unclear and can't be classified until
until there is sufficient scientific
evidence to put them
into one group or the other
so the reclassification
or classification of uh
of variance
it depends on the degree of confidence
for the probability of pathogenicity uh
as your confidence towards
um hypogeneicity improves you will
classify those as being definitely
pathogenic with 99 confidence in the
pathogenicity of it um likely pathogenic
where you have
a 95 to 99 confidence and so on
uh and you have to uh also on the other
hand
be very confident that this is uh the
polymorphism is just a polymorphism to
be a benign variant
um and there are uh american college of
medical genetics has
issued guidelines for uh the scientific
evidence that would allow you
to follow that paradigm of
of the degree of confidence in order to
reclassify
the vus into pathogenic or benign
variants
once the test result comes back the
patient is invited back to have a review
of the test results to discuss the
implications
to uh assess their
ability to absorb the information to
process it to make management plans
and to provide guidance for the patient
and
establish re-contact establish
referrals and so forth so the
possibilities are to have a positive
test result you have
you looked at a set of genes and some
gene
in there identified a risk for the
patient for cancer
uh as you do the multi gene panels you
can have well the patient really came in
with
a history of breast cancer and you did a
multi-gene panel and you didn't have
anything in the
breast cancer genes but you really found
something that gives them increased risk
of say colon cancer
and so that's a possibility and that's
one of the risks of multi-gene panels so
you're basically
providing them with information that
would still be useful
but potentially not something that they
really ask for or directly sought for
that's going to be part of your pre-test
counseling if they're positive then you
are looking at
what the gene is to define
the cancer risks and then further
management recommendations with options
for prevention or early detection and
management
uh it's also important to make a plan uh
to identify
all patients patients family members who
would be at risk
and to make some suggestions or
recommendations
to the patient because you can't really
you're not legally
allowed to reach out to family members
unless you already had a provider
relationship
but to identify those patients for uh
cascade testing or at-risk uh individual
identification and then testing
to be provided to them uh using those uh
generic counseling resources that we
didn't do before
um what to do with the positive test
results based on what gene it is
there are certainly increased
surveillance uh prevention such as chemo
prevention
surgical prevention and then when they
do get a cancer some
there is now an increasing uh repertoire
of
treatment strategies that utilize the
genetic testing information
to target the cancer when it occurs
uh the guidelines for management are
continuously updated nccn publishes
guidelines
uh which are probably the most uh
respected and are
updated at least annually sometimes more
frequently
um
recognizing that even though we're
legally not allowed to reach out to
family members
they really are at risk
and doing appropriate counseling
for patients so that even before testing
this is the ideal time to go through
that counseling
they are prepared to share the test
result
and recognize and are capable of
passing on the benefit of getting this
information to family members
we get those variants of uncertain
significance and
uh the big things to to communicate with
patients is that they need to recontact
uh and typically testing companies will
also recontact them
to update them when the uh the us is
reclassified
but do not act on it uh at the time of
the testing
because it's inadequate data to suggest
that it's going to be pathogenic
or benign uh a greater proportion of
these are going to be polymorphisms of
benign changes
but to not make any assumptions in that
regard and then using
the family history or individualized
risk factors more based on not testing
but
family history to make recommendations
for screening
as necessary okay
um if you have a negative test result
but the patient came in and they had a
significant family history
it really becomes a question of uh what
is known about the family so you have
uh your person your patient is the first
person that's coming for testing
uh or they don't have enough information
or the family has gone through some
testing and they don't have
any known mutation in the family then
your negative test result basically says
well you look at certain genes you don't
really have a mutation in the genes that
you tested for
but you don't have what was causing the
cancer in the family
and therefore you really can't absolve
the patient's
potential risk and vulnerability to
cancer
and so you use a risk estimation method
for um the particular condition
based on family history alone and
uh sometimes can modify it to some
degree
based on negative testing results but
they may remain at elevated risk
on the other hand if a patient has a
known mutation i have a sister who has
a brca one mutation and i'm here and i
have the significant family history but
the history is attributed to the brca
one mutation
we know about in the family and i go
through that testing it's negative
then my risk is very different and i
still have to look at the
risk factors that i have otherwise for
breast cancer
but uh it's not coming from that brca1
mutation because it's not shared
fully but present in the family so
uh what's the level of risk
and then the post-test risk can go down
dramatically
in patients with an unknown mutation uh
in the family that they test negative
there's also patients who will come in
and for
different reasons personal insurance
or otherwise will decline genetic
testing and
our recommendations to them are again
based on the personalized cancer risk
assessment
uh and that they should be considered
trying to understand why they're
refusing the genetic test
trying to make sure that they understand
the benefit that it may provide
for them and then respecting their
desire
as long as they're well counseled well
informed on that decision
and making recommendations still for
prevention or screening interventions
based on their
risk score without including genetic
testing
becomes important
so in summary uh we have a large number
of labs that are
offering genetic testing that includes
multiple genes
with very large number of panels now
available
commercially for testing um
these need to be carefully applied with
justification for whatever test is
ordered
uh it is important to consider adequate
free and post-test counseling
and to interpret those test results in
light of the patient's family history
and personalized risk assessment scores
and to be prepared to deal
with or address any complex
interpretation issues
either independently or with the use of
a genetics professional
and certainly use a genetics
professional
to make sure that you're giving the best
recommendations to the patient
so uh with the patient at the center of
a paradigm there's really
uh the family history kind of
sets you off on a path of defining risk
and defining management strategies
but at that point it becomes uh to me
a multi-uh person professional approach
to taking care of that patient
with the patient at the center within
the pcp
genetics professional and other oncology
or other health professionals that are
adept at
managing the risk for the patient once
it's been defined
become important in the process several
institutions now have groups of
individuals who
are capable and they do all of the
education self-education
to keep abreast of knowledge of genetic
or genetics related risk so that they
can
counsel and manage those patients breast
surgeons surgical oncologists
gi specialist gynecologic oncologist
um and having this collaborative network
so that when your
patient comes back with uh with
enhanced risk you are able to utilize
this network
for management of the patient
the patient is a important collaborator
in this and one of the things that i
have experienced with as we deliver
information to the patient and you
identify multiple risks for the patient
sometimes you have to ensure that the
patient is getting the information but
they're getting it at the pace that they
can actually deal with it as
well and uh then
that's a discussion that happens over
not a single visit but
uh or a couple of visits but in a more
ongoing fashion so they can accept the
information
and go through all of the things that
they need to
until they have a good plan for
management of their risk
so in conclusion we as medical
professionals have an important role
in identifying patients who have a
cancer risk this is typically done by
obtaining a relatively comprehensive
family history and using tools
to identify patients who would benefit
from counseling
use of genetic genetics professionals or
trained clinicians who can provide
counseling
identify and define risk as well as
genetic testing with patients an
understanding of testing options
which are now increasingly complex and
uh
require constant updating of our
knowledge
in utilization of that genetics
professional
to navigate this information with the
patient
becomes important having a network of
providers who have the knowledge and
expertise
to assist your patient
in risk management
and keeping abreast of the growing
knowledge the amazingly growing
knowledge
with the resources available to you now
uh in our uh
networked world uh and using your
local and national resources to
facilitate best care for the patient
uh with that in mind i'd like to thank
you for your time
and my understanding is that
there will be quite an opportunity to
ask questions
which would then be emailed to me and
i'd be happy to take any questions
and provide assistance
certainly in new york state we are at
upstate cancer center and i have
a fairly robust uh telegenetics program
with the counselors that work with me
and we would be able to provide services
to anybody who falls within new york
state we have a license to practice
um and i would invite you to use us as
we can be of assistance
and i appreciate your attention thank
you